Being a historian is sort of like being a detective. You hunt around for little scraps of information, clues you can use to try to piece together a more complete story of the past. You dig through old meeting minutes, receipts, and business transactions. You read old diaries and leave through old letters. And when you can, you try to get your hands on actual physical objects from history. This part can prove particularly difficult because the materials of everyday life are usually lost to the sands of time. Seth Rockman is a professor of history at Brown University, and recently he was looking for clothes that were worn by enslaved people in the American South, which was proving impossible because those items just didn't survive.
作为一个历史学家，有点像是一个侦探。你四处搜寻碎片化的信息，寻找线索，试图拼凑出更完整的过去的故事。你翻阅古老的会议记录、收据和商业交易。你阅读旧日记，翻看旧信件。而在条件允许时，你还会设法接触到历史上真实的物理物件。这部分往往异常艰难，因为日常生活的材料通常早已湮没在时间的风沙之中。塞思·洛克曼（Seth Rockman）是布朗大学的历史学教授，最近他一直在寻找美国南方被奴役者穿过的衣服，但事实证明这几乎不可能，因为那些衣物根本没有保存下来。
They didn't survive because, of course, in most cases, they were used into oblivion through hard labor, or through various forms of recycling. A garment that had worn out might be ripped into shreds and some of it stuffed into holes in a wall to insulate or stuffed into the toe of a shoe or made into a bandage. As a result, very little of the clothing that was worn on slave plantations lasted even into the 1870s. And even if it had, we'd still. be unlikely to find it because many of the cultural institutions that have been devoted to preserving the American past, their collection practices in the late 19th and early 20th century would have had no interest in this, right? Oh, look, I have a garment that an enslaved person wore. Great, come back when you have something that George Washington wore would be more likely what you'd hear. And so
它们没有保存下来，当然是因为在大多数情况下，这些衣物通过繁重的体力劳动或各种形式的循环利用，最终被彻底磨损殆尽。一件穿破的衣服可能会被撕成碎片，其中一些被塞进墙上的洞里用来保暖，或者塞进鞋头，或者做成绷带。因此，奴隶种植园里穿过的衣物几乎没有一件能保存到18世纪70年代。即便保存下来了，我们也很难找到它们，因为许多致力于保存美国过去历史的文化机构，在19世纪末和20世纪初的藏品征集实践中，对这类东西毫无兴趣，对吧？“哦，看哪，我有一件被奴役者穿过的衣服。”“太棒了，等你有了乔治·华盛顿穿过的东西再来吧，”你大概会听到这样的话。所以
these goods would not be preserved in some of the collections. In fact, the clothing that enslaved people wore is so rare that historians have been searching for it for years. So, for example, when Lonnie Bunch, who was the inaugural director of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture, was going about trying to build his collection in the early 20 teens, he was interviewed about the kind of things he was most hoping to find and also least likely to find. And he put at the top of that list, slave clothing. Seth Rockman was looking for this clothing as part of the research for a book called Plantation, goods, a material history of American slavery. It's about all the objects that made slavery possible,
这些物品并没有被保存在某些馆藏中。事实上，被奴役者穿过的衣物极其稀少，以至于历史学家们多年来一直在寻找它们。比如，当史密森尼国家非裔美国人历史与文化博物馆的首任馆长隆尼·邦奇（Lonnie Bunch）在2010年代初着手建立他的藏品时，他接受了采访，谈到了他最希望找到以及最不可能找到的东西。他把奴隶衣物排在了那个清单的最顶部。塞思·洛克曼寻找这些衣服是为了研究一本名为《种植园货物：美国奴隶制的物质历史》（Plantation Goods: A Material History of American Slavery）的书。这本书讲述了使奴隶制得以维持的所有物品，
the hose, shovels, boots, and clothes that were used on plantations throughout the U.S. South. Rockman was not able to find any pants or shirts, but he was able to find a piece of fabric. It happened one day when he was in the archive looking through the mail. One of the pleasures of being a historian is reading people's mail from several hundred years ago. So as I was beginning this project, naturally I went to the archive and called up the records of some of these firms that were engaged in making plantation goods. And I opened up the folders and was very surprised to find that many of these letters were actually not laid flat in typical archival practice, but in fact were still folded, tri-folded. And so I'd be perhaps the first person to unfold some of these in maybe 100 plus years. So as I'm unfolding these letters from merchants in Savannah, merchants in Charleston, slaveholders in Louisiana,
包括在美国南部各地种植园中使用的软管、铁锹、靴子和衣服。洛克曼没有找到任何裤子或衬衫，但他找到了一块织物。事情发生在有一天他在档案馆查阅信件的时候。作为一名历史学家，乐趣之一就是阅读几百年前人们的信件。因此，当我开始这个项目时，我自然而然地去了档案馆，调阅了一些从事种植园货物贸易的公司的记录。当我打开文件夹时，非常惊讶地发现，其中许多信件并没有像通常的档案管理那样平铺放着，而是依然折叠着，被三折叠着。因此，我可能是这一百多年来，甚至更久以来，第一个展开其中一些信件的人。所以，当我展开来自萨凡纳的商人、查尔斯顿的商人、路易斯安那州的奴隶主的这些信件时，
all of a sudden I'm very surprised to see straight pinned to the top of one of these letters a two-by-two square of fabric. And then a letter that describes this is the kind of fabric we want. This is what it should look like. And to recognize all of a sudden there in the paper archive was a material cultural artifact that, in fact, would be used. better and would exceed anything that I might be able to find presently in a museum. This two by two inch square had been mailed from a plantation owner to a textile manufacturer as a way of saying, make us some more fabric like this. Claw squares like this one were sent in the other direction too as a way to advertise the
突然间，我非常惊讶地看到，其中一封信的顶部用直针别着一块两英寸见方的织物。接着是一封信，描述道这就是我们想要的织物，它应该是什么样子的。突然意识到，在纸质档案馆里竟然有一个物质文化人工制品，事实上，它的保存状况甚至会更好，超越了我目前在博物馆里可能找到的任何东西。这块两英寸见方的织物是由种植园主寄给纺织品制造商的，以此来表示：给我们做一些这样的布料吧。像这样的布料方块也会被寄往相反的方向，以此来宣传
types of material that textile companies were planning to sell for the following year, almost like a sample of fabric that you might get in the mail when you order a couch. These little swatches of fabric are all that remains of what was once an entire category of textile. And for your listeners, I would say we have to recognize that the trade name that affixed to this quality of fabrics is a racial term that is discordant to contemporary ears, if not offensive. It is not the most offensive of terms that affixes to race in American culture. But the term is Negro cloth. And again, this is a term that 19th century Americans black and white enslaved and free, north and south would have been quite familiar with.
纺织公司计划在接下来的一年里销售的材料类型，这几乎就像你在订购沙发时在信箱里收到的布料样品。这些小块布料是一整类曾经存在的纺织品仅存的遗迹。对于您的听众，我想说我们必须认识到，贴在这种质量面料上的商品名是一个带有种族色彩的词，在当代人听来很不协调，甚至具有冒犯性。它并不是美国文化中带有种族色彩的最具冒犯性的词汇。但这个词是“黑奴布”（Negro cloth）。同样，这也是一个19世纪的美国人——无论是黑人还是白人，被奴役者还是自由人，北方人还是南方人——都会非常熟悉的词。
But to us, it presents a whole series of mysteries because it's not actually a thing. From 99% Invisible in BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, this little scrap of so-called Negro cloth shows how the plantation economy touched nearly every aspect of American society and how businesses, consumers, and ordinary people rationalize their involvement in slavery. There is a lot to say about this little scrap of fabric that Seth Rockman found. And much of that conversation springs from the fact of where it was made,
但对我们来说，它却引发了一系列谜团，因为它实际上并不是一种具体的东西。来自99%隐形节目（99% Invisible）和BBC工作室（BBC Studios），这里是用100件物品讲述美国历史。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。今天，这块所谓的“黑奴布”的小碎片展示了种植园经济是如何触及美国社会的几乎每一个方面的，以及企业、消费者和普通人是如何合理化他们对奴隶制的参与的。关于塞思·洛克曼找到的这小块布料，有很多话要说。而其中大部分对话都源于它是在哪里制造的这个事实，
because the story we're going to tell starts not in the South, but in Rhode Island. It's 1821. It's been 45 years since the signing of the Declaration of Independence, and it'll be another 40 years before the Civil War rips the country in two. In the south, slave plantations form the basis of an agricultural economy, while in the north the very first mills and factories are popping up, an early sign of the Industrial Revolution that is to come. It's against this backdrop that two brothers in Rhode Island,
因为我们要讲述的故事不是从南方开始的，而是从罗德岛开始的。那是1821年。距离《独立宣言》签署已经过去45年了，而内战将国家撕裂为二还要再过40年。在南方，奴隶种植园构成了农业经济的基础，而在北方，最初的磨坊和工厂如雨后春笋般涌现，这是即将到来的工业革命的早期迹象。正是在这样的背景下，罗德岛的两个兄弟，
named Isaac and Roland Hazard, start a textile company. They know how to make fabric, but they don't know where to sell it, And as they're getting their business off the ground, they get a tip about a lucrative, captive market. They're producing woolen textiles and writing to merchants in Boston, merchants in Philadelphia, merchants in New York, saying, do you anticipate a market for these kinds of textiles? And it is a merchant in Philadelphia who says, you know, many of the southern buyers are in the city this season. and they seem to take a great liking to this as a negro cloth. And all of a sudden, the hazards come to be the leading American manufacturers of woolen textiles that will move from north to south under the name of Negro cloth. It turns out that the hazards have a series of connections through their family to Charleston.
名叫艾萨克和罗兰·黑泽尔（Isaac and Roland Hazard）的人创办了一家纺织公司。他们懂得如何制造织物，但不知道该把它们卖到哪里，正当他们的生意起步时，他们得到了一条关于一个利润丰厚、受控制的市场的线索。他们生产毛纺织品，并给波士顿、费城、纽约的商人写信，询问他们是否预计这类织物有市场？正是费城的一位商人说，你知道，这季很多南方买家都在城里，他们似乎对这种被称为“黑人布”的面料非常喜爱。突然之间，黑泽尔兄弟成了美国毛纺织品的主要制造商，这些纺织品以“黑人布”的名义从北方运往南方。原来，黑泽尔家族通过亲属关系与查尔斯顿有着一系列联系。
And Charleston merchants and then Savannah merchants begin to tell them how desirable their goods are for enslaved people to wear. and invite them to come tour the plantation, see how it works, and learn more about the qualities that make for a desirable Negro cloth. And so, beginning in the early 1820s, one of the two brothers will spend about half of each year, either on the eastern seaboard in the Carolinas and Georgia, or traveling all the way to New Orleans and then setting out on marketing tours up the Mississippi and even over into Arkansas and Texas. And in doing so, they will gather a huge amount of. of information. And one of the things that is truly surprising here is the role that enslaved people themselves will play as informants in the design of these particular textiles. So as the hazards are making these research trips to the South, they would actually get enslaved people's perspectives on the clothing. And I guess given the inherent cruelty of slavery, it is a little
接着，查尔斯顿的商人以及萨凡纳的商人开始告诉他们，他们的商品对被奴役者来说有多么抢手，并邀请他们去参观种植园，看看它是如何运作的，并更多地了解打造一款理想的“黑奴布”所需要的品质。因此，从1820年代初开始，这两兄弟中的一人每年大约有一半时间要么在卡罗来纳州和佐治亚州的东海岸度过，要么一路旅行到新奥尔良，然后开始沿密西西比河向上游进行营销之旅，甚至深入到阿肯色州和德克萨斯州。通过这样做，他们收集了大量的资料。而这里真正令人惊讶的事情之一，就是被奴役者本人在这些特定纺织品的设计中扮演的角色。因此，当哈扎德兄弟去南方进行这些调研旅行时，他们实际上会征求被奴役者对服装的看法。我想，考虑到奴隶制固有的残酷性，我还是会感到有点
surprising to me that enslaved people would have any influence at all over the clothes they wore. It's a really sort of complicated dance that only makes sense if we recognize the tremendous terrain of violence on which it is taking place, right? This is not a situation in which a group of workers have the capacity to negotiate freely with their employers and if they don't like it to go on strike or to leave, right? This is a system of tremendous labor exploitation, predicated on horrific forms of violence, both physical and psychological. Recognizing that, enslaved people like working people everywhere, sought to carve out various kinds of possibilities that might not auger the end of slavery, but that might lessen
惊讶——被奴役者竟然能够对他们穿的衣服有任何影响力。这其实是一种相当复杂的舞蹈，只有在我们认识到它所发生的巨大暴力环境时，这一切才说得通，对吧？这不是一群工人能够与雇主自由谈判的情况，如果不喜欢就可以罢工或离开，对吧？这是一个巨大的劳动力剥削系统，建立在身体和心理的双重可怕暴力形式之上。认识到这一点，像各地的劳动人民一样，被奴役者试图开辟出各种可能的空间，这些空间或许不会预示着奴隶制的终结，但可能会减轻
some of the simply misery of everyday life. So if we think about this as an analogy of workers who are trying to get a five-minute water break as opposed to a four-minute water break, or workers who are trying to trying to get 15 minutes for lunch rather than 12 minutes for lunch. We might think in a comparable way enslaved workers could say, you know, if you outfit us in this kind of performance wear, if you outfit us in these textiles that are of the color or of the cut or of the composition that we desire, you know what? We're going to be less likely to cut off your heads in the middle of the night. And also, we might pick cotton more quickly, or we might not die as frequently from respiratory infections due to morning mists in the fields.
日常生活中某些纯粹的痛苦。因此，如果我们把这比作这样一种类比：工人试图争取五分钟的喝水时间，而不是四分钟的喝水时间，或者工人试图争取15分钟的午餐时间，而不是12分钟的午餐时间。我们可以用一种类似的方式来思考，被奴役的工人可能会说：“你知道的，如果你给我们装备这种工效服装，如果你给我们装备这些在颜色、剪裁或成分上符合我们期望的纺织品，你知道吗？我们在半夜割断你们喉咙的可能性就会降低。而且，我们摘棉花的速度可能会更快，或者我们可能不会因为田野里的早晨雾气而更频繁地死于呼吸道感染。”
And slaveholders are very responsive to this. This is, in some ways, for them, a very easy concession to make. And they are sold on these possibilities largely behind New England manufacturers who tell them. No, no, no. This isn't just a woolen cotton fabric that's 32 inches wide and 14 ounces to the yard. It is Negro cloth. It will provide protection to your investments in human property. It will accelerate the rate of cotton picking in the fields. It will meet your price point. It will allow you to present yourself as a benevolent provider to your people.
而奴隶主对此的反应非常积极。在某些方面，对他们来说，这是一个非常容易做出的让步。他们之所以接受这些可能性，很大程度上是在新移民制造商的游说下，新罕布什尔（注：此处应指新英格兰）的制造商告诉他们：“不，不，不。这不仅仅是一种宽32英寸、每码重14盎司的羊毛棉混纺织物。这是‘黑奴布’。它将为你在人类财产上的投资提供保护。它将加速田野里摘棉花的速度。它将符合你的价格定位。它将让你展现出自己是一个体恤手下人的慈爱提供者。”
None of this is actually true, but it becomes part of the sort of marketing pitch and slaveholders who have their own anxieties and their own political needs and their own psychodrama to, work out in terms of their exploitation of other human beings respond very positively to this. Right. It's interesting this sort of economic interdependence that was developing. Like the North outsourced the agricultural labor and the South outsource the manufacturing of these plantation goods. And, you know, it's become sort of this interdependent system. That's right. We typically think about the divergence of North and South because the Civil War sits on the timeline of American history as this sort of giant black hole with gravitational pull that makes everything that happened before simply road to the Civil War.
这些其实都不是真的，但它成了某种营销推销的一部分，而奴隶主们有着他们自己的焦虑、他们自己的政治需求以及他们自己在剥削其他人类方面的心理剧，他们对这种说法做出了非常积极的反应。没错。这种正在形成的经济相互依赖关系很有意思。就像北方外包了农业劳动力，而南方外包了这些种植园货物的制造。而且，你知道的，它已经变成了一种相互依赖的系统。正是如此。我们通常认为北方和南方是分道扬镳的，因为内战在美国历史的时间线上就像是一个巨大的黑洞，有着强大的引力，使得发生在此之前的一切都仅仅成了通往内战的道路。
Well, rather than thinking about all of the inherent antagonisms between North and South in the 50 years preceding the 1860s, what I've tried to do is show many of the kinds of synergies between these two economies, looking at, as you say, the interdependencies of a southern mode of production that outsources the production of its important inputs and a New England economy that is more than happy to jump into that void as a provider. And one might argue an economy that has functionally offshoreed its slavery, right? As its legal regime has declared slavery no longer viable, as its moral sort of sentiment has turned against slavery as a legitimate form of organizing society, nonetheless.
然而，我们没有去思考1860年代前50年里北方和南方之间所有固有的对抗，我试图做的是展示这两种经济体之间的许多协同作用，正如你所说，我们看到了南方生产模式的相互依赖性——它将重要投入品的生产外包出去，而新英格兰经济则非常乐意作为供应商填补这一空白。人们甚至可以说，这是一种在功能上将其奴隶制外包出去的经济，对吧？随着其法律制度宣布奴隶制不再可行，随着其道德情感转向反对将奴隶制作为组织社会的合法形式，尽管如此，
New England capital has simply moved into other territories and other legal regimes where slavery is A-OK. And like firms that offshore money or offshore production today precisely because there are legal regimes or tax codes or labor regulations that are more permissive to the money they want to make, so too were New England manufacturers able to maintain a very tight relationship to slavery, even as their own communities and their own society became far more skeptical of that institution. So is the goal here to show how complicit the North was in the system of plantation slavery, or is that even the right question to be asking? In some ways, it is an intuitive
新英格兰的资本只是简单地转移到了奴隶制完全OK的其他领土和其他法律制度中。就像今天把资金或生产外包出去的公司一样，恰好是因为那里的法律制度、税收代码或劳动力法规对他们想要赚取的金钱更加宽容，新英格兰的制造商同样能够与奴隶制保持非常紧密的联系，即便他们自己的社区和社会对这种制度变得越来越怀疑。那么，这里的目的是展示北方在种植园奴隶制体系中有多么同谋吗？或者这甚至都不是一个正确的问题？在某些方面，这是一个直观的
response to this. Wow, the North's hands were just as dirty as anyone else's. They were up to their eyebrows and slavery, even as they were denouncing it. What hypocrites? And I suppose when I started this project, that's sort of what I expected to end up with, with a kind of set of smoking guns, showing exactly how deep New England's economy was in the expansion of plantation slavery. But as I went down the road of this project, it also seemed to me that was too easy. And that complicity as a kind of smoking gun, as an aha, gotcha kind of move, was not that edifying when, in actuality, we actually know this. And it seemed to me that it was more interesting as a historian to take complicity for granted.
反应。哇，北方人的手和任何其他人的一样肮脏。他们深陷奴隶制之中，甚至还在公开谴责它。多么虚伪啊！我想当我开始这个项目时，这正是那种我期望得到的结果——找到一系列确凿的证据，准确地展示新英格兰经济在种植园奴隶制扩张中的卷入程度有多深。但随着我深入这个项目，我也觉得这太简单了。将同谋视为一种确凿的证据、一种“啊哈，抓到你了”式的做法，并没有那么深刻的启发意义，因为实际上，我们本来就知道这一点。在我看来，作为一个历史学家，把同谋视作理所当然会更有趣。
That is to say, take complicity as inherent to the human condition for the last 500 years, as global integration has tied people in one place to people in other places through all sorts of commercial exchange. And to ask, how did people live within these structures of complicity? How did people make sense of it? How did people square those circles? And that created a much more interesting, and I would argue complicated way of thinking about economic entanglements not only in the past, but certainly in the present that we currently inhabit.
也就是说，把同谋视为过去500年人类状况固有的一部分，因为全球一体化通过各种商业交流将一个地方的人与另一个地方的人联系在了一起。并去追问：人们是如何在这些同谋结构中生活的？人们是如何理解这一切的？人们是如何自圆其说的？这创造了一种更有趣、我也认为更复杂的方式来思考经济纠葛，不仅在过去，而且在我们目前生活的当下也是如此。
Okay, so getting back to the Hazard story specifically, they do all this research on plantations, and they bring this information back with them to Rhode Island, and they use it to make a product. What did the production of the Hazards Negro cloth look like? So one of the remarkable things about this business is how, much of it doesn't take place in a modern factory space, but rather how much of it integrates certain aspects of factory production with many more traditional holdovers of household production or what would be called outwork. So for example, the hazards could have their yarn spun in a mill, but then they could take scanes of that yarn and deliver it to countless rural families in
好了，回到哈扎德家族的故事上来，他们对种植园进行了所有的研究，然后把这些信息带回了罗德岛，并用它来制造产品。哈扎德家族的“黑奴布”生产是什么样子的？所以，这项业务最引人注目的事情之一就是，它的很大一部分并不发生在现代工厂空间里，而是将工厂生产的某些方面与家庭生产的许多更传统的遗留物（或者所谓的“外发加工”）结合在了一起。例如，哈扎德家族可以把他们的纱线在工厂里纺好，然后把一束束纱线分发给他们社区里的无数农村家庭，并附上具体说明，告诉他们如何在家庭织布机上织布，然后在一个月底回来，从某个家庭收回100码、500码、1000码的布。这些家庭可能投入了一个女儿的额外劳动力，或者丈夫和妻子晚上的劳动力来生产这种商品。哈扎德家族随后将这些布带回工厂，在那里他们可以使用机械化机器来整理、缩绒或起毛织物，为发往南方做准备。所以这是一种奇怪的经济发展模式，其中工厂和家庭并没有对立，而是协同工作来生产这些商品。是的，我想谈谈这种
their community with specific instructions about how to weave it on a household loom, and then come back at the end of the month to collect 100 yards, 500 yards, a thousand yards from a given family that might have devoted the extra labor of a daughter or the evening time labor of a husband or wife into the production of this good, that the hazards would then bring back to a factory where they might use mechanized machinery in order to finish or full or teasel the fabric to prepare it to send to the south. So it is sort of a strange mode of economic development in which the factory and the household aren't in opposition to one another, but rather working in tandem to produce these goods. Yeah, I want to talk about this
材料本身。比如，所谓的“黑奴布”与当时白人体力劳动者穿的布料究竟有什么不同？这正是最引人注目的一点。确实存在一类人人都知道叫“黑奴布”的商品，但它同时也不是一种真实的东西，因为同样的布料，当它被推销给纽约州北部的爱尔兰运河挖掘工时，可能被称为“肯塔基斜纹布”（Kentucky jeans），而当它被推销给俄亥俄州的农民时，可能被称为“威尔士平纹布”（Welsh Plains）。但当它被推销给南方的种植园主时，它神奇地变成了“黑奴布”。然而，“黑奴布”这个词涵盖了一系列不同种类的非常具体的物品。因此，如果你在1840年走进查尔斯顿、萨凡纳、莫obile或新奥尔良的一家杂货店，并说：
sort of just the material itself. Like how different was so-called negro cloth from fabrics worn by, you know, white manual laborers at the time? This is the remark. thing. There is a category of goods that everyone knows as Negro cloth, and it is also not a real thing, because the same fabric that when it is marketed to Irish canal diggers in upstate New York might be called Kentucky jeans, and when it's marketed to Ohio farmers, it might be called Welsh Plains. But when it's marketed to slaveholders in the South, magically it becomes Negro cloth. But Negro cloth is a term that captures within it a bunch of different kinds of very specific things. So if you were to walk into a store, a dry goods store in Charleston or Savannah or Mobile or New Orleans in 1840 and say,
“请把你们的‘黑奴布’拿给我看看，”他们会说：“好吧，这从何说起呢？你是要全羊毛的，还是棉毛混纺的？是要麻毛混纺的？是要平纹织的还是斜纹织的？是要每码10盎司的、12盎司的，还是16盎司的？是要28英寸宽的、32英寸宽的，还是36英寸宽的？是要精细整理的还是粗糙整理的？
please show me your Negro cloth, they would say, well, where to even begin? Do you want it all wool? Do you want it cotton wool? Do you want it linen wool? Do you want it plain woven or twill woven? Do you want it 10 ounces to the yard, 12 ounces to the yard, 16 ounces to the yard? Do you want it 28 inches wide, 32 inches wide, 36 inches wide? Do you want it finished fine or do you want it finished rough?
是要染成蓝色的？还是要条纹的？或者是格子的？”可能性无穷无尽。因此，并不存在一种叫做“黑奴布”的单一物品。有许多不同种类的面料都打着这个伞形概念的旗号，而它们的唯一共同定义就是它们可以作为奴隶的工效服装进行营销。你知道，你对此怎么看？
Do you want it dyed blue? Do you want it striped? Do you want it plaid? Infinite possibility. So there is no one thing called Negro cloth. There are many different kinds of fabrics that travel under that umbrella and are defined solely by the fact that they can be marketed as performanceware for slaves. You know, what do you make of that?
就像所有与种族有关的事情一样，它同时意味着一切又什么都不是？这是一个奇怪的现象，但它在很大程度上构成了种族和物质文化在美国历史中紧密交织的方式之一。能够将某些消费品贴上“黑人”或“白人”的标签，起到了一种作用，即引发关于差异的持续对话，特别是对于谈论布料和“黑奴布”之间差异的白人美国人来说，这成为了一种谈论黑人和白人之间差异的方式。我最喜欢的两位学者芭芭拉·菲尔兹（Barbara Fields）和凯伦·菲尔兹（Karen Fields）将其讨论为一种“种族工艺”（racecraft），一种组织美国文化的巫术，
Like, it's much like all things having to do with race, it means everything and nothing at the same time? It's a strange phenomenon, but it is very much part of the ways in which race and material culture have been very tightly wound with one another in American history. and the ability to label certain kinds of consumer goods as black or as white has done some of the work of creating an ongoing conversation about difference, particularly for white Americans talking about the difference between cloth and Negro cloth becomes a way of talking about the difference between black people and white people. And two of my favorite scholars, Barbara and Karen Fields, talked about this as a kind of racecraft, a kind of sorcery that organizes American. culture to talk about difference, to talk about difference, to talk about difference, race becomes real as lived. And so plantation goods do very important work within this discourse in the 19th century at a moment when white Americans, particularly in New England, are having new conversations about difference, when they're beginning to say, oh, maybe slavery is not right,
用以谈论差异、谈论差异、谈论差异，种族作为一种生活现实变得真实起来。因此，种植园货物在19世纪的这种话语中发挥了非常重要的作用，当时白人美国人，特别是在新英格兰地区，正在就差异展开新的对话，当时他们开始说：“哦，也许奴隶制是不对的，”
or maybe all humans are of one blood rather than of separate creation. And to that extent, the interjection of opinions about, oh, this cloth is only suitable for black people, or this axe isn't the kind of axe that a white person would want to use, or these shoes are inappropriate for black people because they are to this or to that because black people have these kinds of feet or those kinds of feet. All of the goods that are manufactured for use on the plantation fit into this kind of discursive space, and they create a very robust conversation. And what did the people who were involved in making these plantation goods? What did they think about the morality of what they were doing?
或者“也许全人类都是同血统的，而不是分开被创造的。”正是在这种程度上，关于“这种布只适合黑人”或“这把斧头不是白人想用的那种斧头”或“这些鞋子不适合黑人为它们是这样或那样，因为黑人有这种脚或那种脚”的意见介入其中。所有为种植园使用而制造的商品都融入了这种话语空间，并创造了非常强烈的对话。那么，参与制造这些种植园货物的人们又是怎么想的呢？他们如何看待自己所做事情的道德性？
That's one of the most difficult questions to answer. And of course, it was the question that I was most hoping to answer, right? You're a farm girl in Southern Rhode Island. It's 1828. You're spending your fifth hour of the evening sitting at a loom. Are you thinking, my goodness, I'm fulfilling the biblical cause to dress the naked. I'm like a modern-day dorkess. Or are you humming a minstrel tune and engaging in the racist popular culture of your society?
这是最难回答的问题之一。当然，这也是我最希望能得到答案的问题，对吧？你是一个罗德岛南部的农家女孩。那是1828年。你正在织布机前度过晚上的第五个小时。你在想：“天哪，我在践行用衣物遮盖赤身裸体的圣经教导。我就像现代的多卡斯（Dorcas）。”还是你在哼着一首民谣，参与着你所在社会的种族主义流行文化？
All of these things are possible and all of these things are almost impossible to determine with any kind of accuracy. I mean, if we found one diary of one New England farm girl, you know, we have an N of one. And that might not be particularly telling. There are a couple ways where we can think about the relationship of these New England workers to, for example, abolitionism. how many of them would have signed a petition calling for, say, the end of the slave trade in Washington, D.C. And those do exist for many of the communities where this labor is taking place. And one of the things I tried to do was to match names on payrolls with names on petitions. And I didn't find too much overlap.
所有这些都是可能的，而所有这些几乎又都无法以任何准确性去判定。我的意思是，如果我们找到了一位新英格兰农家女孩的一篇日记，你知道的，我们的样本量（N）就是一。而这可能并不具有特别的说明意义。有几种方法可以让我们思考这些新英格兰工人与废奴主义的关系，例如：他们中有多少人会签署请愿书，呼吁比如说在华盛顿特区废除奴隶贸易？对于发生这种劳动的许多社区来说，这些记录确实存在。而我试图做的事情之一，就是将工资单上的名字与请愿书上的名字进行匹配。但我并没有发现太多的重叠。
So it did seem like in a small community like South Kingstown, Rhode Island, the women who were joining the abolitionist society were not the women making. textiles for slaves. But that is also telling in the fact that there is an abolition society in this small town in southern Rhode Island, which means that the kind of families and the kind of people who are making this clothing aren't doing so with no knowledge that slavery is controversial. They're not doing so with no awareness that this is a hot button political issue. I imagine, you know, the farm girl carrying her 50 vests that she's made over the law. last month back to the center of town to turn in for store credits, encountering someone that she knows from Sunday school saying, hey, would you like to sign this petition? Or, hey, do you want to
所以，在罗德岛南金斯敦（South Kingstown）这样一个小社区里，加入废奴协会的女性似乎并不是那些为奴隶制作纺织品的女性。但这同时也说明了一个事实：在这个罗德岛南部的小镇上存在着一个废奴协会，这意味着制作这种服装的家庭和人们并不是在对奴隶制具有争议一无所知的情况下这样做的。他们并不是在毫无意识的情况下将其视为一个热点政治问题。我能想象到，你知道的，农家女孩带着她上个月在织布机上做好的50件背心回到镇中心去换取商店积分，遇到了一个她在主日学认识的人说：“嘿，你想签这份请愿书吗？”或者“嘿，你想不想
come to this meeting this evening? And the fact that this is also in the realm of the possible makes us recognize that this is not an unthinking decision, but this is a conscious decision to see or to not see the ways in which New England labor is tied up with the expansion of plantation labor in the American South. Yeah. And what about the business? businessmen? Like, what about the hazards themselves? Like, what did Roland Hazard think about slavery? Yes. Roland Hazard and his brother Isaac would have described themselves as being against slavery. And that will seem very surprising to the extent that they are running a business for 40 years that's about provisioning slave plantations with clothing. But what they would say is that slavery is not the future, that the world would probably be better without slavery.
今晚去参加这个会议？”而这也是可能发生的事情，这让我们认识到，这不是一个不加思考的决定，而是一个有意识的决定：去看到或者不去看到新英格兰的劳动力是如何与美国南部的种植园劳动力扩张捆绑在一起的。是的。那么企业呢？商人呢？比如哈扎德家族本身呢？罗兰·哈扎德（Roland Hazard）对奴隶制有什么看法？是的。罗兰·哈扎德和他的兄弟艾萨克会把自己描述为反奴隶制的人。考虑到他们经营了一家为奴隶种植园供应服装长达40年的企业，这听起来会非常令人惊讶。但他们会说，奴隶制不是未来，没有奴隶制的世界可能会更好，
but we also have very little possibility of ending slavery. It would be too hard. It would be too complicated. There's nothing really we can do. We just have to hope. It's sort of a thoughts and prayers approach to being anti-slavery. But I'll say one other thing about the hazards that I think sort of explains to me how they make sense of the world. And I think if we time traveled back to talk to Roland Gibson Hazard and said, Mr. Hazard, isn't it true that you have for your entire career skimmed profit off of a corrupt.
但我们几乎没有什么可能性去终结奴隶制。那太难了。太复杂了。我们真的无能为力。我们只能抱有希望。这是一种对待反奴隶制的“想法和祈祷”（thoughts and prayers）式的态度。但我还要说关于哈扎德家族的另一件事，我认为这在某种程度上向我解释了他们是如何理解世界的。我想如果我们穿越时空回到过去，去跟罗兰·吉布森·哈扎德（Roland Gibson Hazard）谈话，并说：“哈扎德先生，难道不是真的吗？你整个职业生涯都在靠一个腐败的人类剥削系统榨取利润。”
system of human exploitation. We'd say, what are you talking about? I'm a philanthropist. You're like, wait, wait, a philanthropist? Get out of here. A philanthropist? No. He's like, hear me out. I'm a philanthropist because, okay, look around South Kingstown, Rhode Island. All these families surrounding us used to be dirt poor, their kids didn't have shoes, nobody went to church. This was a real backwater. Look at these families now. They have a higher material standard of living. They can send their children to school. I have, through this business, you know, tremendously improved my community for the well-being of the inhabitants, but also for the glory of God.
我们会说：“你在说什么？我是一个慈善家。”你会想：“等等，等等，一个慈善家？走开。一个慈善家？不。”他会说：“听我说。我是一个慈善家，因为，好吧，看看罗德岛的南金斯敦四周。我们周围的所有这些家庭以前都穷得叮当响，他们的孩子没有鞋穿，没有人去教堂。这里真是一个穷乡僻壤。看看现在的这些家庭。他们有了更高的物质生活标准。他们可以送孩子去上学。通过这项生意，你知道的，极大地改善了我的社区，为了居民的福祉，也为了上帝的荣耀。”
And meanwhile, look in the South, those suffering slaves, if I didn't make warm and durable clothing for the slaves, the slaves would be naked and that would be worse. So all of a sudden, I'm simply easing the suffering of these people until the day can come in which they can be emancipated. But until that day comes, I will simply turn out yards and yards and yards of patented double-cursy cloth at an affordable price point of 45 cents a yard so that they can stay warmer and healthier than they might otherwise have been. I'm curious about their argument about improving the standard of living in these small New England towns. Were they being sincere about that? Like, were these good jobs for the standards of the time?
与此同时，看看南方，那些受苦受难的奴隶，如果我不为奴隶们制作温暖耐用的衣服，奴隶们就会赤身裸体，那会更糟。所以突然之间，我只是在减轻这些人的痛苦，直到他们能够获得解放的那一天到来。但在那一天到来之前，我会以每码45美分的可承受价格生产出一码又一码获得专利的重磅双面粗呢（double-kersey cloth），这样他们就能比本来更保暖、更健康。我对他们关于提高新英格兰小镇生活水平的论点很好奇。他们对此是真诚的吗？比如，按照当时的标准，这些是好工作吗？
Absolutely. And this is one of the things that I think allowed people like Isaac Peas Hazard and his brother Roland Hazard to see themselves as doing something other than taking advantage of a corrupt system of human exploitation. They were able to significantly raise the material standards of living in these small rural communities where agricultural subsistence was sort of puttering along, but where rural poverty was really quite robust. And to that extent, the way you might compare the lives and livelihoods of small New England farming families in the 1790s to those of the 1840s, those in the 1840s would have more pairs of shoes, more silverware, more calories, precisely because they would have access not to necessarily more farmland, but to an additional source of income that might use the surplus labor time of a daughter or a wife or a son to produce these goods for market.
绝对是的。我认为正是这一点，让像艾萨克·皮斯·哈扎德（Isaac Peace Hazard）和他的兄弟罗兰·哈扎德这样的人能够认为自己所做的不仅仅是利用一个腐败的人类剥削系统。他们能够显著提高这些小农村社区的物质生活水平。在这些社区里，农业自给自足正步履蹒跚，但农村贫困却确实相当严重。从这个意义上讲，如果你把1790年代的新英格兰小农家庭的生活和生计与1840年代进行比较，1840年代的人会有更多的鞋子、更多的银器、更多的卡路里，这正是因为他们不仅能获得更多的农田，还能获得额外的收入来源，从而利用女儿、妻子或儿子的剩余劳动时间来为市场生产这些商品。
And so the plantation provisioning business, the plantation goods, we might call it ecosystem, made them in effect aspiring middle class Americans rather than hardscrabble farmers. And that was really important. Were the hazards ever really confronted with the idea that producing plantation goods was morally problematic and that they shouldn't be profiting off of slavery? Oh, I think they were quite aware of this within local communities. communities throughout New England, but people were constantly bringing this to attention, not necessarily to drive them out of polite society, not necessarily to stimulate abolitionism, but in some ways simply to acknowledge the reality. The best example of this actually comes from a small town in central Massachusetts called North Brookfield, Massachusetts,
因此，种植园供应业务，我们可以称之为种植园货物生态系统，实际上使他们成为了抱负远大的中产阶级美国人，而不是艰难求生的农民。这真的很重要。哈扎德家族有没有真正面临过这样的质问：生产种植园货物在道德上是有问题的，他们不应该靠奴隶制发财？哦，我想他们在当地社区里非常清楚这一点。新英格兰各地的社区里，人们经常把这一点提出来，倒不一定是想把他们赶出文明社会，也不一定是想推动废奴主义，但在某种程度上只是为了承认现实。这方面最好的例子其实来自马萨诸塞州中部一个小镇，名叫北布鲁克菲尔德（North Brookfield），马萨诸塞州，
where a minister named Thomas Snell has been the town's congregational minister since the 1790s. And in the 1850s, he decides to write a town history because he's been there for 50-plus years. And in his town's history, he says, look, when I took the pulpit here, this was a complete hellhole. This was like the worst place on earth. Everyone was poor. Everyone was drunk. No one went to church. Everyone was a blasphemer.
那里有一位名叫托马斯·斯内尔（Thomas Snell）的牧师，自1790年代起就担任该镇的公理会牧师。在1850年代，他决定写一部镇史，因为他在那里已经待了50多年。在镇史中，他说：“看哪，当我在这里担任牧师时，这是一个彻底的人间地狱。这里就像世上最糟糕的地方。每个人都很穷。每个人都醉醺醺的。没有人去教堂。每个人都在亵渎神明，
it was misery everywhere you turn. Look at us now, 50 years later. We have seven Bible society, six abolition societies, four lyceums. We don't have anyone who's drunk. We have no one who's living on the street. Our children are well-clothed. They all go to school. They all look good.
无论你转向哪里都是痛苦。看看现在的我们，50年后的今天。我们有7个圣经协会，6个废奴协会，4个讲演协会。我们没有任何人喝醉。没有人露宿街头。我们的孩子穿得体面。他们都去上学。他们看起来都很好。
We have nicer houses. We have nicer things. Why is this? And then he says, the answer everyone knows is slave shoes. and that not $1.50 passes through the hands of the town people through a source other than slave shoes. But then he goes on to explain, this doesn't make slavery right and it doesn't make shoemaking wrong. It's simply a fact that we have to acknowledge about our prosperity. Snell is someone who hates abolitionism, who thinks that people like William Lloyd Garrison are the worst and far more dangerous to American society than slaveholders.
我们有更漂亮的房子。我们有更好的东西。这是为什么呢？”然后他说：“每个人都知道答案是：奴隶鞋。”而且“除了奴隶鞋之外，没有1.5美元是通过其他来源经由镇民的手流通的。”但接着他继续解释道：“这并没有让奴隶制变得正确，也没有让制鞋业变得错误。这只是我们必须承认的关于我们繁荣的一个事实。”斯内尔是一个痛恨废奴主义的人，他认为像威廉·劳埃德·加里森（William Lloyd Garrison）这样的人是最糟糕的，对美国社会的危害远大于奴隶主。
So it's not part of simply an abolitionist critique. it's simply a discussion of acknowledging the fact that New England prosperity goes hand in hand with Southern slavery, and to deny that is to deny a very basic reality. This equilibrium is disrupted when the Civil War breaks out. What happens to the hazards and where do their allegiances lie? So much to my surprise, most of the New England manufacturers of plantation goods are not dragged kicking and screaming into the Civil War. This is, as they see it, not the worst thing that could ever happen to them. And the reason, there are a couple reasons for this. One, they have a particular soft landing. Why?
所以这不仅仅是废奴主义批评的一部分；这只是一种对事实的承认，即新英格兰的繁荣与南方的奴隶制密不可分，而否认这一点就是否认一个最基本的现实。当内战爆发时，这种平衡被打破了。哈扎德家族发生了什么？他们的效忠对象在哪里？出乎我的意料，大多数种植园货物的北方制造商并没有被踢打着、尖叫着拖入内战。在他们看来，这并不是可能发生的最糟糕的事情。原因有几个。第一，他们有一个特殊的软着陆。为什么？
Because now there is a huge demand for low-quality cloth, low-quality shoes, low-quality hats through the U.S. Army. The mobilization of the Union Army creates opportunities for cloth that last year was called Negro cloth, this year to be called Infantry Man Blue. or whatever it might be. And so they don't basically suffer a great deal from the loss of their southern markets. But perhaps more importantly, they have this fantasy, and that attests to, I think, what we might see as their more general anti-slavery commitments, that in freedom, black people in the South
因为现在美国陆军对劣质布料、劣质鞋子、劣质帽子的需求量巨大。联邦军队的动员为那些去年被称为“黑奴布”、今年被称为“步兵蓝”或是其他什么名称的布料创造了机遇。因此，他们基本上没有因失去南方市场而遭受巨大的损失。但也许更重要的是，他们怀有一种幻想——我认为这证明了我们可以视其为他们更普遍的反奴隶制承诺——即在自由状态下，南方的黑人
are going to be far better consumers than they could ever be as slaves or that their enslavers could ever be as consumers, and that the ability of four million freed people creates four million liberated consumers who are going to have money in their pockets through wage labor, that they can then spend on a second dress for their wife or a pair of shoes for their children, and that this is going to be a source of tremendous prosperity for New England manufacturers in the decades to come. Now, they are sadly wrong about this, the violence of reconstruction and the violence of sharecropping, particularly its system of debt peonage, means that black Southerners in freedom do not become significant consumers. They do not
将比作为奴隶时、或者比他们的奴隶主作为消费者时要好得多。四百万获得解放的人口创造了四百万获得解放的消费者，他们将通过劳务获得薪水，口袋里有钱，然后可以为妻子买第二件衣服，或者为孩子买一双鞋，这将成为未来几十年新英格兰制造商巨大繁荣的源泉。现在，他们在这一点上可悲地错了，重建时期的暴力和佃农制的暴力，特别是其债务奴役制体系，意味着获得自由的南方黑人并没有成为重要的消费者。他们并没有
become a market. I mean, it is amazing to me that the hazard genuinely believed that reconstruction might create a class of free black workers with enough money in their pocket to buy a new shirt every year. Like, that is, it strikes me as hopelessly naive. It didn't work out that way. And it didn't work out that way for reasons that we in the United States still don't have a full accounting of our ignorance collectively about the violence of reconstruction and about the ways in which white supremacy was reestablished in the South and the ways in which the largest slaveholders were once again back on top of an economic system that devoted ever more amounts of southern labor, black and white, to the cultivation of cotton. We need that story. We need to recognize, for example, that the American South remained the world's most important producer of cotton for the industrialized economies of places like Britain and the American North. It did so not because ending slavery created a free labor paradise in which everyone can simply earn abundant wages set by the market for spending hours in a cotton field, but through vigilante violence, through debt peonage, through the inability of people to move for higher wages at risk of getting shot.
成为一个市场。我的意思是，令我惊奇的是，哈扎德家族竟然真的相信重建可能会创造出一个拥有足够资金每年买一件新衬衫的自由黑人工人阶级。这给我的感觉是无可救药的天真。事情并没有那样发展。而且事情没有那样发展的原因是，在美国，我们至今仍未对重建时期的暴力以及南方白人至上主义死灰复燃的方式，以及最大的奴隶主如何再次回到经济体系顶端的方式进行全面的清算——那个经济体系将越来越多的南方劳动力（黑人和白人）投入到棉花的种植中。我们需要那个故事。我们需要认识到，例如，美国南方仍然是英国和美国北方等工业化经济体最重要的棉花生产国。它之所以能做到这一点，不是因为终结奴隶制创造了一个自由劳动的伊甸园，让每个人都能仅仅通过在棉花地里工作几小时来赚取市场设定的丰厚工资，而是通过治安维持会的暴力、通过债务奴役制、通过人们为了更高的工资而不敢冒着被枪杀的风险进行迁移的无能为力来实现的。
and that's really important here. Yeah. Ultimately, look, what do you want people to take away from this study of plantation goods? Well, obviously, as a historian, I want people to know some new things about the United States in the 1820s, 1830s, and 1840s. But let's be honest. This book is not just a book about the past. This is a book that is very much about our present and the ways in which the long distance and tangents are, of consumers and producers, create all sorts of ethical, environmental, moral, political dilemmas that we find ourselves very much in. And I would say that the evolution of this book, for me, went hand in hand with things in our society around, say, trying to establish our carbon footprints and to lessen them, or going to the university bookstore and finding out how much
这在这里非常重要。是的。归根结底，听着，你希望人们从这项关于种植园货品的研中获得什么启发？嗯，很明显，作为一名历史学家，我希望人们能了解1920年代、1830年代和1840年代美国的一些新事物。但说实话，这本书不单单是一本关于过去的书。这本书很大程度上关乎我们的现在，关乎消费者与生产者之间的长途运输和各种衍生关系，这些关系引发了各种伦理、环境、道德、政治困境，而我们正深陷其中。我想说的是，对我而言，这本书的演变过程与我们社会中的一些事情息息相关，比如努力确立并减少我们的碳足迹，或者去大学书店看看有多少
of that branded, logoed merch is now declaring itself to be sweatshop free, or trying to buy fair trade coffee, or thinking about where our university endowments are tied up in weapons production or other kinds of economic pursuits that we find unsavory. And this has been one of those places where I feel like my students in particular have pushed me so hard on this to look at the ways in ways in which. which we are all tied into these economic relationships, but also to be cognizant of the great difficulty of extracting ourselves, particularly as we think about the tradeoffs, right? Oh, I'm very much interested in lessening carbon outputs and my own dependency on carbon-based
带品牌和标志的商品现在声明自己是无血汗工厂生产的，或者努力购买公平贸易咖啡，或者思考我们的大学捐赠基金是否与我们觉得令人反感武器生产或其他经济追求挂钩。这也是我觉得我的学生们在这方面对我推动极大，让我去审视我们所有人如何被卷入这些经济关系的各个方面，同时也让我意识到要将自己剥离出来的巨大困难，特别是当我们考虑到其中的权衡时，对吧？哦，我对减少碳排放以及自己对碳基
fuel, so I'm going to move to an electric car. Oh, well, wait, haven't you thought about the violent production of rare earth mineral materials in West Africa, aren't you then complicit in that kind of exploitation? Oh, how wonderful that you're using a paper straw. Yes, I know, but I'm doing it on an airplane that I'm flying to California to see my family, and so I've sort of, you know, obliterated any kind of good. Don't you care? We exercise a good deal of consumer agency in the global north, but it is not a consumer
燃料的依赖非常感兴趣，所以我打算换一辆电动汽车。哦，等等，你难道没有想过西非稀土矿产材料的暴力生产吗？那你难道没有同谋于那种剥削吗？哦，你用纸吸管真是太棒了。是的，我知道，但我是在飞往加州看望家人的飞机上这么做的，所以我基本上已经抹杀了任何所谓的善举。难道你不在乎吗？我们在全球北方行使了大量的消费者能动性，但这并不是一种
agency that at present is really tilting the scales in ways that create a more just and more fair society or planet. And so what I want for people who read this book is to say these dilemmas are in fact not new. We are not the first people who are challenged by an integrated global economy. A globalization was not invented with the WTO in the 1990s, right? I mean, you know, as we're talking about the sort of offshoring of misery, basically, that feeds this economy. The offshoring of misery is getting further and further away from us. The mechanisms are more obfuscated. They're more abstract.
目前真正能倾斜天平、创造一个更公正、更公平的社会或星球的消费者能动性。因此，我希望读这本书的人能够明白，这些困境其实并不新鲜。我们并不是第一群被一体化全球经济所挑战的人。全球化并不是在20世纪90年代随世贸组织诞生的，对吧？我的意思是，正如我们所谈到的那样，基本上是苦难的外包支撑了这种经济。苦难的外包离我们越来越远。机制变得越来越扑朔迷离。它们变得更加抽象。
Is this an excuse? Is this just means we have to dig deeper? Is this something that we have to contend with in a different way? I wish I had a good answer for that question. And I'm afraid I don't. It does seem to me that an awareness simply of these kinds of entanglements, an awareness of global supply chains, a commitment to writing more people's experiences into the ways in which goods come to exist within our lives in the privileged West. But the erasure of all that, right, is so fundamental to capitalism is so fundamental to what Marx had called the commodity fetish, right? It is all about erasing the prehistory.
这是一种借口吗？这是否意味着我们必须深入挖掘？这是我们必须以不同方式应对的事情吗？我希望我对这个问题有一个很好的答案。恐怕我没有。在我看来，仅仅意识到这些纠缠，意识到全球供应链，致力于将更多人的经历写入那些存在于我们这些享有特权的西方人生活中的商品的创造过程中，这似乎是必要的。但是抹杀这一切，对吧，是资本主义的基础，也是马克思所说的商品拜物教的基础，对吧？这一切都是为了抹杀其史前史。
And so it does seem to me that there is a political project that you and your podcast are engaged in. Your listeners are certainly engaged in to basically pull back that veil, to open that black box and to say that things don't come into the world fully formed as commodities. They come into the world and become commodities through knowable historical processes that often involve individual or social decision making, that involve the deployment of all sorts of power, personal and state, and also involve a great deal of cultural work to then invisibleize all of the things that go into making the world look the way that it does. Well, Seth Rockman, this has been such a fascinating conversation. I really enjoy your work. I really enjoyed the book. I really appreciate your time. Thank you, Roman. My pleasure to be with you today. Seth Rockman is the George L. Littlefield Professor of American History at Brown University.
在我看来，你和你的播客所从事的确实是一项政治事业。你的听众也确实在致力于拉开这层面纱，打开这个黑箱，并指出事物并非以完全成型的商品面貌来到这个世界上。它们通过可知历史过程进入世界并成为商品，这些过程往往涉及个人或社会的决策，涉及各种个人和国家的权力的部署，也涉及大量文化工作，从而将所有让世界看起来像今天这样的事物隐形。好了，赛斯·洛克曼，这是一次非常迷人的对话。我真的很喜欢你的作品，我也很喜欢这本书。非常感谢你抽出时间。不客气，罗曼，很高兴今天能和你交流。赛斯·洛克曼是布朗大学的乔治·L·利特尔菲尔德美国历史教授。
He is the author of Plantation Goods, a Material History of American Slavery, which was a finalist for the Pulitzer Prize in history. A History of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Emmett Fitzgerald. Our series producers are Priscilla Al-Bee, Brenna Daldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken.
他是《种植园货品：美国奴隶制的物质历史》一书的作者，该书曾入围普利策历史奖决赛。《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。本集由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作。我们的系列节目制作人是普里西拉·阿尔比、布伦娜·达尔多夫和埃利·莱特富特。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯完成。
Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. from BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Sirius XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in Beautiful, White City, West London.
我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99% Invisible的执行制作人是凯西·2。来自BBC Studios的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是Mabel Finnegan Wright，艺术设计由斯特凡·劳伦斯负责。99% Invisible是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区。BBC Studios总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。
If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想与我们联系或有物品让我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至100 Objects at 99PI.org。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。